the moment there is little in the way of
physical infrastructure to tell drivers
they are crossing the border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic unless
you want to stop for gas on one side of
the border you'll pay in Euros on the
other in pounds
everyone here is used to coming and
going with ease but now brexit is making
things complicated at the moment the UK
including Northern Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland are two independent
states both are in the European Union
and have a bilateral agreement that
allows free travel between the Republic
of Ireland and Northern Ireland if the
UK leaves the EU as planned the rules
will change an external you border would
be put up between Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland and it would
have to be secured after all the EU has
strict rules on which products are
allowed to be imported or exported and
under which conditions the problem is no
one wants a hard border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland
border patrols and guard posts are
symbols of one of the darkest chapters
in Ireland's history the Northern
Ireland conflict the troubles in which
more than 3,500 people were killed
starting in 1969
only with the 1998 Good Friday Agreement
did the violins come to an end
together with EU support the deal paved
the way to peace many worried that the
conflict may flare up again in the
course of the UK's exit from the EU and
several attacks in recent months
suggests that this concern is not
unfounded but how can brexit take place
while preventing a hard inner Irish
border at the same time a comprehensive
customs and trade deal between the EU
and the UK would be one solution but
this has yet to be agreed that's why the
EU has proposed the so called backstop a
kind of insurance that if needed
guarantees there will be no hard border
on the island of Ireland the backstop
stipulates that the whole UK would
remain in a customs union with the EU
following brexit until a better solution
is found which basically means that
trade would remain as is for the time
being but with one key difference the UK
would have to abide by EU regulations
even after brexit yet would have no say
in the rules after all the country would
no longer be an EU member so it's no
wonder that the backstop is so
controversial in Britain Prime Minister
Boris Johnson sees it as unacceptable
but he has yet to propose an alternative
all sides could live with and so the
Irish border question remains the
greatest obstacle on the long road to
brexit okay so we saw there what a
tricky issue this really is in brags and
negotiations but what is the plan on the
table right now to break this deadlock
well to me we don't know exactly the
details of the plane we do and we don't
know any legal language what we do know
what suggested is that Northern Ireland
will effectively be some sort of hybrid
it will somehow be aligned to the
European Union but in other
waise also it will still be a member of
the UK and this is you have to go back
to basically a very good report Northern
Ireland is is a special case and the
beauty of the peace process of the Good
Friday Agreement that we've had so far
is that people in Northern Ireland could
feel as UK citizens they could feel
British but they could also feel our
Irish as Europeans and I think this is
what they are trying now to achieve in
these negotiations and Brussels but
crucially all eyes will be on the DUP on
the Northern Irish party if they support
what's being negotiated in Brussels then
I think Boris Johnson has a good chance
of of getting his deal through also here
in London but if they don't all bets are
off